[Applaudissements]
chers collègues j'ai un rappel réglement
que je vais prendre qui est celui de
Monsieur Cazeneuve et puis je donnerai
la parole à l'orateur ce qui se passe ce
soir ne peut pas être passé sous silence
des députés sont sortis de cette
émission parce qu'ils n'ont pas gagné au
tirage au sort et quand l'un de leurs
collègues qui a été condamné pour avoir
frappé son épouse prends la parole sur
un amendement vous restez stoïque pire
que ça vous applaudissez
bon allez c'est scandaleux c'est nous
j'adore parce que vous avez vu les
députés parfois ils se vénèrent comme ça
ils prennent le micro il faut comme ça
genre c'est tout pour moi
alors
bravo Aurore berger
parce que franchement elle est du
courage c'était la seule qui a pris la
parole très vite et l'autre là
Clémentine autant là ton ami il a ta
copine là
Claudia Adrien
mais d'ailleurs il y avait une gêne même
sur le même sur le du côté de la France
insoumise parce que il y en a qui sont
partis Sandrine Rousseau a quitté
l'hémicycle par exemple d'autres sont
partis d'autres étaient plutôt gênés
n'ont pas applaudis mais on voyait que
ils étaient du côté de la LFI mais ils
n'ont pas applaudit et puis d'autres se
sont carrément levés pour applaudir
la patronne des des verbes elle est
c'est la nouvelle patronne des Verts
elle a dit tout simplement et c'est pas
cassé la tête c'est compliqué qu'il
revienne
déjà qu'il revienne Cyril c'est déjà
extrêmement contestable à l'Assemblée
mais qu'il prenne la parole
d'accueillir en musique il voulait
mettre du Patrick Fiori que tu reviens
tout de suite
silence qu'il aurait dû s'imposer
lui-même c'est ahurissant de lui donner
la parole évidemment qui a eu des et moi
je ne comprends pas comment il peut
intervenir comme ça publiquement alors
quand même qu'il a été condamné à 4 mois
de prison avec violence et les suspendu
il est suspendu du groupe et les filles
jusqu'en avril on est quand même en
février
non comme l'a dit tout à fait clairement
tout à l'heure Valérie je trouve
effectivement les applaudissements
étaient totalement indignes la moindre
des choses ça aurait été un silence
absolu voilà et il aurait dû et que lui
soit discret il aurait dû en fait
démissionner et se faire réélire
éventuellement par ceux qui l'ont élu
députés non mais c'est une bonne idée
moi j'ai compris je comprends pas ce que
vous fait une Castaldi
pas compris je pense la gravité de ce
qu'il a fait ces gens qui
l'applaudissent ils ont pas compris lui
il croyaient quoi qu'il allait revenir
au calme à l'Assemblée qu'on allait rien
dire c'est n'importe quoi et pour moi un
député il doit être exemplaire je suis
désolé quand on a frappé sa femme quand
on a tapé sa femme comme lui on a pas sa
place à l'Assemblée alors il a pas
mesuré la gravité c'est pour ça qu'il
est là de voilà et interdit de présence
c'est pour ça
tu discutes avec quelqu'un oui oui je
disais un député que c'était scandaleux
Jean-Marie bravo tu vois et parler avec
qui
c'est ma femme mais elle me disait
rentre
ridicule rentre tu crois pas qu'on a
assez de problèmes d'argent comme ça
c'est ça tu veux qu'on paye plus je me
faisais engueuler mais c'est là qu'on
atteint les limites de leur hypocrisie
où elle est fille la France insoumise ça
c'est on arrive aux limites de tout ils
ont dénoncé tout le monde et vas-y les
gens ils savent gueule dans tous les
sens des femmes le grand combat des
femmes et ben là on voit où il est tombé
de combat des femmes malheureusement
en fait son intervention il a quand même
commencé en disant qui a dit il a cité
une phrase de Macron qui s'était renié
pour autre chose pour les retraites
alors moi je vais dire je vais faire la
même chose je vais faire le même procédé
Adrien katnas qui a dit sur les bandes
de l'Assemblée nationale en octobre 2019
parmi les 118 femmes tuées par leur
conjoint ou ex une proportion
significative avait porté plainte ou
déposé une main courante combien de ces
cas aurions-nous pu éviter combien de
ces cas étaient prévisibles mais n'ont
pas été prévenus nous devons combler les
failles qui a dit ça Adrien catenas en
octobre 2019 donc voilà c'est c'est tout
il aurait dû faire vraiment profil bas
et c'est honteux ce qu'il a fait elle
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est incroyable après il y a pas
d'humour
mais je parle après c'est vrai que bon
ceux qu'on a côtoyé voilà bah il y a
entre un mec qui a des violences
conjugales et un mec qui dit l'heure
c'est vrai que ça fait beaucoup pour un
seul parti quand même c'est étonnant
d'ailleurs qu'aucune Commission se soit
pris en main cette histoire de Deal un
député qui a dit lait qui l'a reconnu
officiellement il devrait s'y intéresser
à mon avis il a dit à la télé il a dit
dans les journaux c'est pas normal tu te
dis qui dit que la police tue dans les
sur les bancs de l'Assemblée
un député RN qui a été qui a été
suspendu pour moins que ça l'autre jour
donc je crois qu'il a dit les dégradolas